President Bush comes up and I interview  him and he talks personal life what  things he did what things he changed  just being very open about the whole  thing and then we're doing pictures  succession with pictures  and I cannot tell you how many people  who were you know not supportive and  send me messages you shouldn't have  brought him you shouldn't have done this  they're like look I don't know if I  agree with policies but I like the guy I  kind of like him on how he is you know  wow I like this guy this would be a guy  I would want to have dinner with and  then so every time everybody was taking  a picture half of them were happy to  take the picture the other half were  like I got to tell you I thought look  one girl said I thought you were the  Antichrist but I like talking to you  this was amazing listening to you thank  you so much for coming out